lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es ver
las dos maneras de interpretar esta
minúscula que ya hemos visto en varias
ocasiones que los libros de textos se
las van a presentar como menos 9.81
metros por segundo al cuadrado y 9.81
metros por segundo al cuadrado hacia el
centro de la tierra en este caso la
cantidad negativa significa o indica la
dirección hacia donde ocurre esta fuerza
es hacia abajo y probablemente la forma
más típica de interpretar este valor es
la aceleración
aceleración
debida a la gravedad
de vida
ala
gravedad
cerca
de la superficie de la tierra
para un objeto y eso es lo que nos vamos
a enfocar en este vídeo
para un objeto en
caída
libre
y la razón por la que hago énfasis en
esta última parte es que imagínense y de
hecho ustedes conocen muchos objetos que
se encuentran cerca de la superficie de
la tierra pero que no están en caída
libre por ejemplo yo estoy cerca de la
superficie de la tierra pero no estoy en
caída libre lo que sucede conmigo en
este momento es que estoy sentada en una
silla esta es mi silla y aquí estoy yo
sentada muy tranquilamente
le dibujó las patitas a la silla y esta
silla soporta todo mi peso de hecho es
por eso que tengo las piernas aquí
dibujadas suspendidas en el aire no
tocando el suelo así que esa soy yo y
qué está pasando en este momento si yo
estuviera en caída libre estaría
acelerando hacia el centro de la tierra
a 9.81 metros por segundo al cuadrado
pero lo que está sucediendo aquí es que
toda la fuerza debida a la gravedad toda
la fuerza debida a la gravedad está
siendo compensada por completo por la
fuerza normal de la superficie de la
silla hacia mis pantalones así que esta
va a ser mi fuerza normal y voy a
expresar ambos como vectores que eso es
lo que son vectores así que la fuerza
neta en esa situación
mi fuerza neta
aquí es igual a 0 sobre todo en la
dirección vertical y debido a que esta
fuerza net es igual a cero yo no me
estoy acelerando hacia el centro de la
tierra por lo tanto no estoy en caída
libre y debido a que este menos 9.81
metros por segundo al cuadrado sigue
siendo relevante en mi situación y
hablaré sobre ello en un momento pero
insisto no estoy en caída libre otra
forma de interpretar esto es no como la
aceleración debida a la gravedad cerca
de la superficie de la tierra para un
objeto en caída libre una forma más
general de interpretar esto es el campo
gravitatorio de la tierra y realmente es
la aceleración promedio aceleración
promedio ya que está cambia ligeramente
sobre la superficie de la tierra pero
esta otra forma de interpretarlo es el
campo promedio de gravitación en la
superficie de la tierra vamos a escribir
esta otra interpretación en este tono el
campo
campo gravitatorio
gravitatorio
promedio
promedio y en un momento hablaremos de
lo que significa campo en el contexto de
la física el campo gravitatorio promedio
en la superficie superficie de la tierra
tierra
esto es un poco abstracto pero nos ayuda
a pensar en cómo se relaciona en este
escenario cuando tenemos objetos que no
están en caída libre cuando hablamos de
un campo en el contexto de la física es
algo que asocia una cantidad a cada
punto en el espacio esto es
una cantidad
para
a cada punto
cada punto en él
espacio y puede ser una cantidad de
escalar en cuyo caso le llamaremos un
campo escalar o podría ser una cantidad
vectorial en el cual se tendría una
cantidad y una dirección para cada punto
en el espacio en cuyo caso estaríamos
tratando con un campo vectorial y la
razón por la que estamos llamando a esto
un campo cerca de la superficie de la
tierra es porque si ustedes me
proporcionan una masa aquí sabemos que
la masa está dada en kilogramos que se
encuentra cerca de la superficie de la
tierra y digamos que esta masa de aquí
es de 10 kilogramos
podemos usar g para calcular la fuerza
real que la gravedad está teniendo sobre
este objeto en este punto en el espacio
por ejemplo si esto tiene una masa de 10
kilogramos y eso de aquí es la
superficie de la tierra y aquí
tuviéramos el centro de la tierra aquí
tendríamos asociada una cantidad
vectorial cuya dirección es hacia el
centro de la tierra y cuya magnitud va a
ser la masa del objeto muy
y cada por g minúscula y podríamos tomar
este valor ya que estamos especificando
la dirección 9.81 metros por segundo al
cuadrado hacia el centro de la tierra y
en este caso esto sería igual a 10
kilogramos por 9.81 metros por segundo
al cuadrado lo que es igual a 98.1
aunque esta cantidad está redondeada es
en realidad un número aproximado
entonces esto es 98.1 kilogramos por
metro / segundo al cuadrado y esto es la
unidad de la fuerza esto es igual a 98.1
newtons y esto podría no estar en caída
libre y es por eso que este eje es
relevante aún en situaciones cuando no
tenemos una caída libre que nos da la
fuerza por unidad de masa de la gravedad
en un objeto cerca de la superficie de
la tierra y este campo lo que nos da es
fuerza fuerza entre masa
así que si ustedes me dan una masa cerca
de la superficie de la tierra ya sea que
esté en caída libre o no lo esté si
multiplicamos esa masa por g ya que nos
está dando fuerza por masa tendremos la
fuerza de gravedad actuando sobre ese
objeto cerca de la superficie de la
tierra esté o no en caída libre así que
es por eso importante esta distinción
sobre todo cuando nos están dando la
gravedad así y pueden pensar que esto no
es relevante en esta situación que no
hay caída libre pero si es relevante
obviamente aquí no pueden decir que mi
aceleración cuando estoy yo sentada en
esta silla es de 9.81 metros por segundo
al cuadrado hacia el centro de la tierra
ya que yo no me estoy acelerando
recuerden que esto no es sólo una
aceleración así que a esto no podemos
llamarlo solamente aceleración aunque es
cierto que cuando tenemos un objeto en
caída libre y está saque de la
superficie de la tierra y si no tenemos
resistencia al aire si la fuerza neta en
realidad es la fuerza de gravedad
entonces eso sí sería la aceleración del
objeto pero eso sigue siendo relevante
aún para los objetos que no se
encuentran en caída libre
y conocemos a muchos de ellos y sabemos
incluso que los objetos en caída libre
no se encuentran mucho tiempo en caída
libre
eventualmente caerán y darán contra algo
pero sabemos que esta analogía en
realidad es relevante para todos los
objetos que se encuentran cerca de la
superficie de la tierra nos dice la
fuerza por la masa y podríamos estar
tentados a llamarle a esto siempre una
aceleración ya que estas unidades son
las de la aceleración pero cuando
estamos hablando en términos del campo
gravitatorio va a seguir siendo la misma
cantidad va a seguir siendo esto seguirá
teniendo las mismas unidades la misma
magnitud e irá hacia la misma dirección
solo es una manera diferente de ver esto
aquí está como aceleración en caída
libre y aquí está como campo
gravitatorio algo que multiplicamos por
la masa para encontrar la fuerza debida
a la gravedad